f qui va arriver dans le coin voilà bah
écoute et j'espère que vous allez bien
ce soir masse organisé un petit tournoi
et voilà je sais pas si vous avez mater
un peu le foot à la coupe du monde à
belle victoire 5 0 de la russie bon je
trouve que l'arabie saoudite ne veut pas
très très bien je dois dire et les
russes les russes en pleine forme
voilà bomba demain demandera trois
matches bon ça parle pas et chacun sait
pas vous mais là vous voyez j'ai on a
mis sur l'écran la partie d'une nouvelle
jouer jouer hier on a fait une vidéo
dessus tout à l'heure est grave
c'était une belle partie contre naka je
voulais je vous la recommande voilà
sinon ben je sais pas je ne peux pas
jouer pour pas être accusé de tricherie
que le groupe de cairns
mais du coup on va un peu meublé en
discutant quoi voilà tout ça je compte
sur vous dans l'oeuf par le chat un
petit peu voilà bah sinon budapest
budapest sympa
quoi dire bon moi est une petite dizaine
pour le stage s'est bien passé il reste
encore un jour de cours demain
après il sera temps de rentrer voilà
prêt moi récemment j'ai pas trop bien
joué c'était si mes résultats
ça arrive et vous donc un peu déçu mais
c'est comme ça quoi
voilà voilà bon je sais pas si je peux
prendre mon compte peut-être faire une
petite partie
on va voir grégoire qui est là-bas
écoute salut grégoire j'espère que tu es
en forme ce soir ce soir petit tour moi
je pense qu'on commencera vers 20h30
20h35
on va on va créer sa petit à petit
d'ailleurs ce que je peux le faire a
carrément une arène oui pour faire comme
toi quoi c'est pas faux du coup c'est
vous alors comment créer un tournoi
bon je sais les rejoindre déjà c'est
bien tu vas sur tournant à droite
ouais c'est ici d'accord club tournament
la vrai nom on va l'appeler arena le
vrai l'unique
la blies stream standard time control
3way aujourd'hui 20h30 novateur même ma
20h20 en fait puisque les mais qu'elles
peuvent arriver en avance
20h30 novateur tranche du vin du hcdh
une et combien de temps les trois une
ouvrière riner bat comme ça mais 20h
france à 20h30 21h30 c'est bien m'a dit
qu'est ce que tu veux faire des petits
plis de savon je suis pas sûr je suis
pas sûr je suis un petit format se
regarde un peu le chat parce qu'il
raconte
ouais bah c'est bien des progrès doit il
dit c'est toi qui fais la reina enfin
c'est nous qui la créent au moins ils
pensent être qu'on va jouer une arena
mais à pas mais il n'y a pas de fin la
fosse arena il veut dire les fausses
arenas et les lundis et mercredis
et là en photo et qui avait pas de put
roger parce que ben dabbab stage ouais
donc déjà élevé des cours et mâcha si en
plus que jouer le soir c'est chaud et
puis jamais sûr de la connexion quoi bon
il a toutefois plutôt sûr qu'elle ait
pas tape en fait pour dire la vérité je
dise à peu dans le politiquement correct
faire des commentaires mais la vidéo du
jour marche pas mal pour des comptes en
clair que pour la petrov c'était la cata
mais la coupe après il n'y a pas grand
18 personnes
alors est-ce qu'on est sur une chaise
comme terrorisc du goût quand on est
séparés semaine dernière ils ont oublié
de placer make it shirts à mansle être
apte à regarder non attends je vais sur
le téléphone parce que c'est lui qui va
rester ou pas stricker stamm
automatiquement ces thèmes très
intéressant free qui sommes heureuses je
sais pas pourquoi pas à l'imiter enfin
gardons mike est sûre ça très bien selon
club est ce que je sais tombe en rade de
batterie pour le match mais je sais
d'annoncer nous maintenant vouloir stamm
les gens qui le regarde et séisme
arrivent à niveau à chaque arrivant à
chasser horrible est-ce qu'on voit
vraiment à l'écran mais moi une pro b
est en tout cas on voit ouais voilà on
ne voit pas trop à fond un peu baissé
ouais mais je te je te rendrai la place
à t shirt rock nantais bien là aurait
peut-être que le défi un peu des gens
que je veux du mas servons dix minutes
histoire de faire voyons même alors
attends je regarde le chat du truc dans
mais c'est une bonne idée mais je
regarde un peu c'est ce qu'est ce que je
vais le chat soit très envie d'ouvrir le
deuxième chat sur le smartphone tu vois
ça tu le papa août
on fait déjà grincer sur la petite roue
mode autonome va comme ça tu peux fermer
la fenêtre tu te papa août voilà une
sage femme et du coup merde on a perdu
des messages qui avait tant pis partie 1
falls avoir tort mode jlg du web est
nouvelle coupe de cheveux rasage de
barde pendant un nouveau départ de sa
part de là en fait un nouveau départ le
capillaire déjà d'après forage au kobus
qu par fo muscu après dix huit mois mma
ou pas à terme le tarn dans huit ans que
je pourrai défier ouais j'suis tendrait
la main comme ça tu donnes des rdv pour
faire du 1 v1 voilà donc pour l'instant
j'espère ne pas être défiée trop vite
quoi c'est un os que tu donnerais le rdv
regarder sous un regard dit souvent pour
leurs débuts en v1 quoi hop hop hop
enfin pas mais moi mon petit monsieur se
fait vite endemol c'est pas des gens le
bon point qui vont me sais pas est ce
qui nous définit ce que santos boxing
fait boire le top est l'armé de chasse
est même assez au dessus je pense tu as
aimé votre sur d'autres choses boxing
mais par contre déjà on peut concevoir
chessboxing effectivement là la grosse
bosse comme il ya zéro personnes
inscrites sur le tournoi du couple
donc merci à personne qui s'inscrit tu
peux rappeler comment s'inscrire au
tournoi
non non mais s'il ya des gens qui
demandent oui mais sinon ça tu
entretiens 1a et bien le big boss hays
favori là du coup pour l'instant seuls
participants
attention comme hier pourquoi pourquoi
on n'a pas de instagram d'ailleurs bah
je sais pas j'ai toujours méprisé ce
truc je t'accuse aussi j'ai vu que ça
devenait que en fait facebook
c'est en train de devenir le réseau
social des vieux et genre nous on est
dessus lors de des vieux ben ouais mais
en fait on a la trentaine on est juste
des vieilles merde et il me dit est ce
qu'il faut pas parce qu'en fait on me
dit que tous les jeunes sont souvent des
objets élites de la nation est sûre sur
un style star'ac
ok j'ai jamais trop capter de snapshot
l'intérêt d'avoir un truc ça se détruit
enfin je sais pas mais bon on cite hugo
muscu tu as envie d'envoyer des photos
vous mais je voterai le bras comme ça
m'arrive mais je pense qu'en fait il
faut muscu pour faire sa place
non mais je pensais faire quoi tu as
beau smartphone est toujours au
changement de la tête je prends dix
personnes face à cet amas voir m'occupe
de faire instagram mais je sais pas
enfin il ya pas mal de bouffons qui
prennent leur bouffe en photo et on en a
rien à [ __ ] en fait
après les stars pourquoi pas un match of
questi toi tu prends une photo tu
prépares ton ta partie ton truc
pourquoi pas tu vas à la plage c'est
joli mais vas-y gourgaud créhin
instagram bitstream en direct chez quoi
on peut créer à l'instar du tout a dit
si toi tu es créent maintenant je go
créé instagram par contre j'ai pas mon
numéro de téléphone dont il faut que je
paye ton téléphone
bon ben on le gars m'ont rentrer dans la
modernité ont rajeuni de dix ans mais du
coup en fait si je veux créer un état
grave je go muscu quoi on est obligé
pareil je vais bonus qu il ya des gens
qui écrit dans le chatt prévoir si gros
muscle ou pas alors ton téléphone je
peux pas te le dire aux deux fois dessus
sauf si tu reçois des open ah ouais non
non les dix points froide jamais être
harcelé d'appel après salut pierrot
coucou les raye ouais c'est un fait non
mais facebook on va dont certaines ont
plus de messagerie tu vois qu'on avait
mais ça avant car je fais plus rien
dessus j'ai quand même intéressé ou faut
il me dise pas autoriser l'application
instagram a envoyé consulter des sms bah
je refuse par ailleurs de nombreux mais
je vois déjà consulté mes sms quoi enfin
je veux dire nongo refusé on peut du
coup vous ne pouvez pas créer deux
contres non mais j'aurais dit non mais
en fait légèrement sas pour pouvoir mon
code de way genre la chance je regarde
ton code de toi tu rentrer le code de
confirmation je prends tu en train de
pas le recevoir
je reçois pas d'autre part mike goodson
non il envoie par sms
mes chances étaient très énervés que je
leur dise non tu vois je la découvre des
gens donnent de meilleurs titres
bon du coup cette année chaque et comme
le tournoi toujours qu'un inscrit
ça y est je vais le code sacré pari pas
de chance
d'ailleurs poutine il a fait un pas de
deux mecs au milieu aussi là le présent
bleus n'avaient pas ou feint l'italo
suisse mais qui sait peut-être que c'est
un vrai en fait coup ci ce serait génial
c'est intéressant mais bon le problème
les mecs c'est que le plan de base ce
serait que fab joue donc je vous
explique un bon qu'on vous pas même pas
même sexy fable ou six rencontres ont eu
lieu avec les pleurnicheuses villon de
nenê il triche je préfère ne pas faire
la touche a que des preuves pour
poursuivre sa conversation alors là la
vie casa nous dit hello c'est quoi le
programme bas le programme c'est que
nous organiser un tournoi dans 20
minutes
mais tu peux déjà t'inscrire bien sûr
pour l'instant les canes inscrit donc le
tournoi je crois que elior avère très
favoris pour l'instant mais tu peux le
concurrencer quoi vous faire un v1 la
haye à bègles qui arrivait donc pour
l'instant c'est un vrai entre abel mais
chose certaine arena 2 way et violent
voilà un filon du sud a bondi suite un
petit peu donc comme on disait on est
toujours à budapest encore deux jours on
rentre ronde samedi
le voilà c'était plutôt cool simpliste à
jouer mais on peut être qu'on va avoir 1
2 verre dans le tournoi je sais pas il
ya déjà un mec là tu dois le dénonçait
du show
melesse permettent de tirer sa part toi
d'heureuses real bitstream
maintenant je mets billy stream officiel
comme les stars dégage identifié plus de
18 ans si je veux à personne
voilà tant pis moi je mets plus ouais ok
ok lapiro est très très contents de la
vidéo sur leur cible
ils me disent de trouver vos amis à sur
la base de vos amis grégoire s'est dit
trim trade hub à autre et du six
officiels très du trade huîtres et
l'autre à du bas rhin le stream officiel
comme ça non ouais ouais
et vas-y que reprendre une première
photo représente la base je suis
personne pour le moment dégage
je ne suis personne j'ai bientôt quitter
la maison sans autorisation à sa gamme à
accéder à vos contacts
parce que les mecs bargot autorisé
instagram à parce que tu peux doit être
au nombre de quatre banques lâche quand
même pas retenu cette photo non
publication mais non mais enfin réagir
dégage
y en a marre quoi par contre j'ai suivi
ma femme peut-être ça changerait pas les
entrées oui bah ça oui ça fait bien
qu'ils aient envie soisson s'en fout
attends je suis ma femme du coup il veut
accéder à la position de mon appareil
non mais attends mais aucun ma vache
vers le mec en fait il veut tout comme
on l'a j'accepte on s'en fout de façon
il ya plein d'applications qui le font
ne sait déjà pas très normal
oui mais j'en parle abondamment le mec
me pose trop de questions belle vague
des autorisations de tout pour tous de
petites minutes pour qui messi je vais
aller voir les gens je leur dirai quand
est-ce que tu quittes motoriste a compté
critique les clichés toi tient ses 39
ans est-ce que tu m'autorise à prendre
ton téléphone là mais ça va alors à
temps du coup mais c'est très
intéressant cela eh bien je pense que on
est complètement en train de mon élève
le niveau là vous avez vous des boks
complètement donc les ja piero qui a
rejoint le tournoi et dispatch aussi du
cours des quatres on a 1 2v de la pas
mal combats de catch qui ça ne t'a pas
le gens qui ont le même nom pour ma
femme c'est fantastique dont 7,9 qui est
assez mignonne dans la g je leur faut le
savoir
c'est vérifiable walser team tam thoune
qui dit qu'il devait tourner alors
comment il fait pour tout le tournoi
avoue qu'il s'inscrive au club nous est
ce que tu as inscrit au club lite stream
qui me donne tout le temps je suis en
train de lui en train de suivre des gens
là sur instagram s'affiche en bas âge as
tu fait à lille il faut faire un pas je
suis là quoi je suis des gens
patrick prend la photo quoi mais alors
comment on fait alors à temps le premier
film est autorisé l'application samax et
des autres fait quoi je n'en peux plus
vous en savez être autorisée quand même
brad on ne voit pas sur un site web et
pancrate photo toute façon le m salut
hbcd ok les pierrots il est dir est bien
quand j'ai besoin de dire pierrot écrite
ou dans l'autre châtre merci pierrot
quoi tout ce bleu non mais je sais pas
mais là là je sais pas si j'ai pas si
j'ai lu et vail non mais c'est de la
merde
photo non pas prendre ça en première
photo sébastien être horrible différents
4 pourri non mais c'est tellement de la
merde je ne fais pas tu te veel à part
tout est à créer avec le ce trio
d'arrières merci
c'est un jeu mais aussi sur toi assis
sur family
je vais essayer de chercher family parce
que j'ai cette photo il ya d'autres
personnes dessus c'est génial mais cache
quoi ta famille caf et attend qu'on va
les y voit le montage quoi est-ce que
vous dressez oui oui je m'autorise quoi
jamie le truc c'est la première fois que
faith matin à la photo est complètement
notre génial plastique attends je mets
des filtres c'est seulement en noir et
blanc en garde
regardez la classe s'intéresse à la
jument noir et blanc allaient
j'enregistre hymne à l'ancienne le micro
tout à les suivants publier des news
dans de la pluie sur facebook sur
twitter de partout mais non non juste
astrium a ajouté une légende je suis
déjà je veux dire je met debout une team
dit fribourg un truc comme ça
le stream le hashtag non mais c'est beau
quand même ce stream ont réussi à faire
un swing création d'un stade gronde au
stadium
ils me disent de finaliser je finalise
essayer plutard ckoi [ __ ] je sais pas
ça y est elle en ligne de leurs photos
sur instagram vous vous voyez je suis un
boulet pour l'occasion bon faudrait bien
plus je suis au bon faute à des coups
bas je fais un petit bullet après tu
reviens commenté l'aréna on est partout
bon alors ça enlève un peu spéciale en
direct de budapest regard et je compte
le shérif la rue où tu es complètement
nul je te fasse un chrétien chirila
ouais bah je joue dans l'esprit 1
il en sur sa chérie la en sueur caissier
là c'est quoi ton projet allez vous
gbagbo je cois bah oui pas pour projet
de tour âges de tous rachats maths mais
bon il va sacrifier la dame et j'ai rien
cacher sa qualité de l'équipe france et
4 quand vous avez de très mauvais la
gueule ils seront propres que vous voyez
là qu'est ce qui se passe d'après je
fais tout rejet 5 non ce n'est pas dans
l'esprit
non mais ok il faut prendre la dame
normalement mais oh non on blague
ok j'ai super laguë qua non mais j'ai
lac de folie quand je le fais une chance
pas de chance un mot qu'elle gagne juste
parce que je l'avais en fait mais en
gros j'ai fait j'ai fait un bijou ouais
on tente de prendre la dame je défonce
wen après pour les arénas me mais perdre
de l'eau par cessera psychiko ali prend
des points c'est un beauf attend on va
le retrouver lui en donner une deuxième
où il fait une deuxième on s'en fout je
voudrais l'esprit à fond philippe
prochaine arena hamburg à marrakech
complètement dominant la première femme
à prendre le pion au delà bien non mais
c'est pas mal tu vas pas stratégiquement
par rapport aux 3 arena c'est bien en
plus de jouer n'importe quoi ces coûts
ça me fait une réputation c'est un peu
comme au poker
tu vois la cdu free money ses juges ou
des frigos la libye la coica melo 25 68
ce que je sais pas très bien ce que je
disais mais bien sûr
à
je crois
je suis mal an
mais bon sait rien
il s'écarte à detroit
comment je les primes ou
attention oui mais ça empêche pas de
faire qu'est ce que t'es nul bon ça va
c'est tranquille les médecins me donnent
arinç japon le savoir de ton film au
théâtre viendront le train de total
c'est ce qu'on a appris pendant le stage
dans les mecs
enfin si la cuisson quadrillé tout ce
qu'on est en débit j'adore que par là
c'est un peu con je suis mal d'accord
bon je me protège ah bon on va la perdre
malheureusement j'ai décidé encore
passer cinq mois que je suis quand même
très mal la litho damman waimes
stratégiques s'est dé free roll je lui
met sous pression quand sarah jouer pour
du vrai ce sera fait la même quoi
mais je crois que c'est super chiant
quand les mecs se joue n'importe quoi
comme moi la face à aux caractères en
fait c'est trop l'impression de perdre
printemps noir et blanc trame un jeu lac
de nouveaux ballons perdus alors mais
j'ai bien fait de pas faire le l'aréna
les infobulles est à savoir la mort du
malade en fait mais je pense qu'il se
rend compte qu'on le troll ou pas je
veux oui si je monte mon élan en bullet
comme c'est très important pour la suite
de ma carrière
art ce baume est ce qu'elle est partie
quand même hein c'est juste super con
quoi ainsi madame est la marque du saas
et un niveau de ridicule qui est enfin
qui dépassent l'entendement quoi dieu
des jeunes oui mon frère presse le
niveau intrinsèque qui parle j'ai plus
de temps quoi j'ai pas très vite mal
sourit mythique est cassé en fait c'est
un deuxième problème non dégage tu sais
comment j'ai envie de la gagner cette
partie mais mon jeu pas si j'y
arriverais femmes arrivent à me faire
tomber en fait de faire à 4 mars est nul
ça
ça joue mal je prends le centre j'ai vu
ce matin ça joue super malin c'est
horrible que faire
là il met la pression sur le centre avec
le canadien certes on ne sait pas
passionné par ce par le haut niveau donc
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france est
ce que quand tu vois un joueur comme ça
qui se pose et qui dirait ça important
ce qui se révèle tu vois ma main si
elles foutent l'emprise aaa à aa
c'est tellement ridicule je te sens
tellement insu en train de regarder
ben moi ce que la france joue comme ça
c'est que ça tellement rien à voir avec
les échecs c'est juste super con que
j'adore le faire c'est 3
je comprends pas trop ce qui fait la
parade jaillit prend le seul prend des
risques
non mais je pense que j'ai rien mais
enfin je trouve que amiens somme ça je
referai pu faire plus simple non je
pense
maquillage je revois la voiture manque
tu la prends oui
la leaf est retour des quatre caisses et
les grands maîtres chiens sans le savoir
je recycle ou quoi mais c'est génial
j'étais complètement p r ça fait
formalité c'était de cette sphère tour
des cas pour lui donner la tour quoi il
est carrément particulier comme ont peur
je suis très content franchement j'ai
une très bonne position
on va le changer les draps clairement ne
me dérobe pas fait attention des gens
que tu manges dos il faut parfois aux
larmes
moi je sais où je veux aller bouffer le
cap je vais commencer par à 3 mais
changer ça une fois je vais [ __ ] à
angers 2 et je vais le feu quatre en
fait peut-être peut-être pas encore mais
ça je suis assez bien sentie de
l'ouverture on compte parmi eux
ça ne peut pas aller il faut que je me
concentre là j'essaie de faire afficher
6 x 3 peut-être dû faire flasher trois
prochains parce que j'ai besoin de faire
un petit truc quoi
des talents des 5 avec le caresse fait
chaud on va chasser et coûte 1
car à faire bkc 5 ha oui c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre que je suis en train de
faire ah mince léger lag sept off by the
mega la gu nam ok j'ai perdu que dix
secondes joujou mais bon y'en a marre
mais sinon je la gagne ça l'est encore
maroc est vrai que ce n'est qu'un jour
je domine encore comme ça hallucinant
non sur le tournoi a commencé
ouais bah on regarde quoi ça tient de
chasse aux puces c'est nico nico nico
nico nico nico nico nico allez allez
allez allez nico aller nul contre lens
fait nico nico nico la tempête l'anoci
coup aussi jeune âge
ouais je tiens ici
yazami kevin tu es trop lent qu'on ne
l'a cru quoi
nico nico olé olé olé olé nico nico
tapas on n'a pas un truc à faire tourner
je prends une chemise pour un truc quoi
faire du nicolas font pas moi je pose de
fer nico nico nico j'enlève la chemise
pas chômé faut qu'on le fasse en même
temps la chemise quand un train d'être
enlevée et ont fait demi coiffe le
peuple et la cua allez on fait du niko
belic au pays comme il comico ni corps
ni corps ni corps ni corps ni connico en
fait une yole à gauche molle a vraiment
itam tempo nico vuvuzelas nico nico
c'est du commentaire d'échec ça ni leoni
co à allez allez allez allez nico nico
allez allez allez allez nico nico hier
de l'hôtel et tu es toi tu m'en fout
quoi ni celle qu'on appelle mme delahaye
s'écoulera hissant la mission soit
puissions commenter la prod la mâche un
écran de chez ce tour là oui le truc bon
nous on commente alors à petit la prime
des commentateurs monstres et maxime fou
prend ces cinq nouveaux
au reçu que nico enfin toute la réserve
peut-être que nico il a dégoûté de la
force at attention ben non 17 comme dans
la salle a rajeuni qu'au dessus de tout
c'est plus fort même que vous prend et
boum nico plus vite on s'en fiche haut
niveau ce soir dit que je dois au niveau
ça arrive avec nico tu t'attendais
parlant choco allez nico boulicaut qui
se dé cloud c'est quoi c'est tout est ce
parce que c'est la mine guillon c'est
pas à temps le chat de check points
comme ça parce que je pense sont
complètement fous sur le chat orient
devient sont complètement con les deux
nico nico il ya 100 spectateurs à peine
pour entendre nico nico pas quand je le
connais et ils sont partis quand il
était ici c'est 97 et sans plus que 80
puisqu'ils seront parfaits tout d'un
coup quoi les noeuds je suis content mon
malade comment ça va mieux là ça m'a
réchauffé coach of legends et crise par
une chaîne de chasse comme non plus ne
sont pas là soit parce qu'on voit bien
pourquoi pas rock
ben ouais c'est conceptuel peut-être par
infosys ou
darry cowl qui on dirait version de
nikos et shoah elle faisait ce qu'en
fait l'arrêt cardio sirugue stage et que
en fait c'est jack
ouais c'est soit zac allée des quatre
nico nico nico je vous entends d'un
match 4-6 très fort prépare des 4es par
dame prend b4 ni qu il est chaud le nico
nico il est chaud patate ça se mange ça
vous non c'est pas quoi ni quoi
peut-être d'autres idées vous a déjà
surpris c'est moins frappée d'apprendre
et catherine barma tour des huit mois 4
e 4 pts est dans l'esprit je donnais
adam après force est quand même fou
cette direct bout ça c'est pourquoi
passer tout mon esprit
bah je pense que nico prendre à temps
les l'aréna en fait c'est vicieux parce
que tu peux aller voir faut qu'on
retrouve nico pas nico qui a pas de
partout vraiment et que huit joueurs
dans l'aréna bon faut le savoir pourquoi
les chats disparition se déconnecte j'ai
perdu autant à cause de sa musique
yasmina khadra ma mort ce soir
mary callahan andy rihs nations unies
veux c'est jouer en direct c'est
malheureux mais nico en fin de rencontre
ont notre ami pierrot quoi des rails
sahara est la merde qu'on peut être ce
qu'on peut vraiment être contre l'élite
manigod bull à cela depuis ce matin le
stage pierrot comment ça se fait que tu
josé chaque été au travail on voudrait
savoir en fait c'est très intéressant
du coup après on va décider sans y
porter au pape a nommé ron les plus
horribles cecchini qu en voix basse et
chez opus la cgso people
oui mais bon les gens n'est pas obligée
de savoir bon après je la mets rangnick
aux familles ou une phrase à gaza de la
mayrand et nico le titre ce matin
tu as a eu un coup de speed là le nico
nico tu as j'ai vu comment on a un peu
cassé avec par le stage quand même ce
qu'on fait pas mal de choses on a fait
pas mal de sorties les mecs approuvé
quatre nico on avait dix baies 5 pouces
mais il ya des belles sorties à faire à
budapest c'était vraiment cool mais on
avait dit plus tôt b57 position dans
cette jolie ville
bikey défouler cette c5 en gros 5
pour faire simple fou mais quatre coups
des deux bons mais peut quand même faire
rock effet pour ces 5 1 et sur 1 3 il
reculera et tant pis
ça va c'est une violation franchi plein
axe et parapublic
bakiev évoqué un tablier peut-être fait
tour 8es e520 jeu des fous tu peux pas
garder la pression ferme et non plus tu
as de service et ben je sais pas mais je
sais pas comment on fait un nico on y
croit bref ça fierro qui joue bien que
ça fait m la tour ans et un test fait
retour aux 8,5 m fabre à tour des huit
j'aime pas trop
je pense qu'il peut tenter mais au sein
même des cinq back eyed peas 6 tab et si
j'ai un peu des deux mais on y est à 5
vous faut cette fois 3 j'allais dire
alors
pierrot était bien ton foot piero qui
romont pas frangins mon poto mon copain
qui me tient chaud pierrot bon sarah
stocker pour les blancs mais c'est
dommage qu'on foute liste noire c'était
quand même un patron c'était un rake ou
nico qui est très mal autant vous le
savent et sur re5 j'ai peur de kayes g5
ils tous dit quoi c'est fou quand les
gens et puis qui très bien pour défendre
comme ça en plus ce que j'ai dit ce
matin là c'est vrai mais c'est vrai mais
il avait plus de temps non mais
nomade dans l'âme et quelle femme est
folle cavale amabilités ces prix
résistent tinkoff grosse game de pierrot
mais n'a pas fait dans le premier
non ça ne marche pas donc assez logique
je suis qu'à l'épreuve 7 mai mais aussi
financier provient cette marche mais
pouvaient s'ils souhaitent cette
coiffeuse psp ls ménages jugés pirou et
rejoindre des réseaux de chaise quand
les deux leaders bombes ont reçu quoi
mais il ya tellement peu de gens qui
sont venus participer aux trucs mais tu
vois je pense
taran tu remarques qui fait pas un je
dis qu'il est pas une foi et une cour en
place ou s'il se passe chez pas inscrit
une fois et légendes à vue ils perdent
habitude toute fusion ces trois ans que
ça durait n'y a pas eu à jeudi je me
souviens plus
dans mon trip talent contre le pierrot
du coup pierrot pierron des offres ouais
mais c'est là petrov c'est ça pète on
compare à les voir ce qu'ils écrivent
qui est toujours malade toi tu es un
petit peu de ta de la fièvre on sait pas
en fait ouais on en fait on arrive pas à
savoir si alpha molo à de fab libye a de
la fièvre ou pas en fait on on
s'inquiète un peu pour alpha bibi car
oui jma news écrit je trouve le titre
mauvais mais cool
jade de la vidéo max match prouve que
les pièces c'est de la merde ils
n'aiment pas ils n'aiment pas le titre
même si comme cool mais ouais mais quand
même content non mais sérieux non c'est
pas un titre enfin pour moi le titre rio
avec la partie quoi faut dire c'est
l'occasion de faire une petite dédicace
et machin la crypte aldata qui permit
que le roi de pierrot
je sais pas si ses gardes l'aja pas en
cherchant un peu relou krew [ __ ]
[ __ ] roja du coup les couilles montrer
qu'il a des cojones n'ont même pas trop
pour des pions comme ça se savoure tout
les colonnes de tout est à prendre de
façon sûre sur 24 la tourache 1 je vais
apprendre d'eux va reprendre dans 24
pays les très peur pour leurs ouailles à
peut-être fait retour j'ai quatre tours
j'ai un toit à doubler ou tourache un
tour g1 damage ça pense que c'est
complètement gagnant pour cris table on
va voir je crois que nicolas s'est
déconnecté donc carton plein
je crois que c'est raide un damage 5
je fais comme la gamme enrichie force et
le g5 d'autres si tu pries kiss tour g1
du prix quand même
qui est il faut faire
magic 3 8 je comprends qu'il ait fait ça
avant la clown pour s'enfuir
ouais bon la belle attaque de cryptage
ouais j'ai bien peur que nico de retour
bah allez nico et mon nico qui joue pas
mal et qui mériterait un meilleur
classement franchement ils peuvent vous
pouvez très bonne partie mois il peut
jouer très bonne partie de nikko mai
mais je sais pas il mérite mieux que ce
qu'ils que ce qui fait quoi attention
d'être fataka nouveau en tête faire d'un
v6 pu en prendre un problème si square
face à calais puis dessous moi je vais à
ses petits cahiers prend 1,5
donc elle fit par allociné d'un v6
d'impro liste pourquoi pas après tout
calcul beaucoup plus vite que moi ça on
s'en est rendu compte
damman pas non mais je le trouve pas
optimale je remarque que tu beaucoup
mieux qu'au mois précédent
non mais là non mr gérant général est
vraiment beaucoup plus fort que moi en
fait d'un messi argentine
non mais c'est cher c'est la vérité
faire à prévoir mais je remarque je
calcule plus victoire et tu as une
meilleure intuition sur les bons coups
le seul truc à manger gueuler tout en
floride sa garde mais avant cela les
aléas sismiques haut de la gorge coup de
patte de vous serez comme ça c'est pas
mal a devancé justin sutil gratte
c'est là que ça vient désolé les mecs
sains d'âge et julien perret lauper non
mais je sais pas je passais mon verre et
toutes les relations de toulouse tout
moment c'est sûr nous sommes super peur
ni sûr à 100% bas
un succès venu dans la gorge
notre pénible mais déjà hier un truc
le seul truc zain jeu tous aussi quand
je suis peut-être aussi bien que toi ou
a même mieux
en fait c'est son seul point faible
aussi je pense je suis beaucoup plus
pratique et pragmatique que toi tu
envoies ouais j'en vois n'a rien je
pense que tu me mets dans tous les
compartiments tu comprends mieux mais on
va dire que j'ai plus de conviction dans
ce que je fais ce qui est bizarre mans
est hyper important aux échecs bonne
mais je pense que si telle est la
conviction t'aurais minimum 25 56 je
veux faire une conviction mais en fait
j'en suis sûr qu lancer ton seul point
faible en fait non mais c'est mon seul
homme c'est plus un point de faire
pratiquer d'ailleurs que des chats et
complète que le niveau ne pas commencer
sa fière cette conviction pour eux vous
confiance ou peut-être que je serais
peut-être tu te mets la pression aussi
nous tu respecte trop chambre c'est un
mélange de trucs comme ça non plus
jamais trop convaincu je vais gagner ou
quoi tu es tout seul en place tout seul
hier c'est le seul entre guillemets
compartiments du jeu même si c'est pas
cher et là tout à l'heure tous comme ça
en fait
donc moi je vois des vieilles femmes je
reste la tendance a prévenu qu en fait
c'est marrant parce que ce truc là de
mal joué par gérard de conviction et
tous étaient tellement un point fort bah
c'est tellement bizarre en fait quand ça
discute un peu sur le chat lancions j'ai
été leur nom mais c'est le toit pour les
vieux renard de nico va perdre non nico
a gagné nico waouh ses forces à trois
centièmes
ok mais de moins de vingt joueurs dans
l'arena mais c'est bien ce que personne
ne sache qu'on va en fait pas si peu de
gens sont inscrits à l'arrivée en fête
premier vidéo y en a vingt à trente
personnes qui jouent et l'a8
c'est étrange je voyais sur l'autre
chatte y est impossible d'y participer
faute sur le le club jazz comme vitrine
aussi c'est peut-être parce qu'elles les
examinent en ce moment il ya le bac qui
démarre très bientôt là ils ont
peut-être que tient le regard des
requêtes contre le crystal chronicles of
ouais c'est le répertoire de deux
berceaux ne joue pas mal non notamment
inspiré par ton livre vous ce qu'il
achetait tombe je connais sur la canal
maghreb a tenu par l'opt et tuer les
femmes c'est autographes je pense qu il
est ferme site photographe n'était
heureux quoi
non mais c'est sympa d'avoir
l'autographe de l'auteur
le chip haut mais il s'est fait une
bonne partie jusqu'au 20e fallu quand
même contrat unique et 2003
si tu prends pas comme ça tous comme de
connard ça c'est arrivé non mais je dors
je te font c'est là le plus fou que ça
s'en remettre mais ce parce que tu
arrêter de fumer de nouveau la menace si
vite c'est bizarre ça mais quelques
jours d'habitude on n'a pas eu le rythme
de vie le plus sur adam des 5 séries
romain j'allais dire c'est pas si clair
mais vous faire des cinq questions étant
programmés la page et un brouillage
instagram
dans cette bd follower ouais on peut
voir un fait saillant sipholo j'aime pas
on voit nos fauvet rail 12v grigoire un
peu d'autres joueurs d'ici quoi j'ai une
copine caraquet s'il fait toujours
pleines d avoir qualité qui cette fille
mais bon c'est toujours plein
durant sa carrière par delahaye l'ancien
pas plus qualifiés s'effondrait si le
live déchets que tu m'as tu me dises et
instagram la niche à quoi qualifiant
pour nico plus le spectacle d'ouverture
différentes à chaque fois de 4,5 sicilia
française ou du jeu varié donc on va pas
le plus important c'est qu'on ne va pas
le père des enfants malheureusement on
cherche je cherche avant tout à la fois
de plus en plus qualifiés
c'est plus qualifiés comme toi tu
comprends mieux quoi le plaisir d'un
refus de lightman
le premier arrêté instagram et
qualifiant l femmes aux hommes femmes
libye ont su leur badge infos que je
comus q moi j'adore cette expression
faut que je me musculeux gnl
je pense va tout le temps le commu ce
qui enlève tous les atouts les célestins
attend qu est ce que ça raconte sur le
fait des réalisations prévues des défis
banon non non on suit le tour une
tournante unico quoi le bac démarre
l'année c'est à dire dans trois jours
mais c'est bientôt quoi donc et préparez
vos ligue 1 mais faites attention aux
greffes serait con de rater là dessus
donc ça la vie après un vous prévoyez en
demande sur quoi ont participé à faux
faux participer au club bitstream
surclasse comme et puis après tu peux
t'inscrire au tournoi gagné je comprends
vraiment pas pourquoi il est si peu de
voix en fait
alors est ce qu'on peut s'inscrire à
postériori ou parler normalement mais le
principe de la nano plus de hashtag de
leurs te dis no way
après ces essais la première fois tu vas
progressant hashtag c'est ma femme qui
va s'en occuper son truc mais réaliste
et plus pour les jeunes instagram et que
fait il que facebook était grand pour le
combat mais si on m'a dit sajjad encore
plus pour les jeunes et youtube en fait
pour les plus jeunes ces messieurs elle
ne voit plus bornés vrai on est que là
ya pas de jeunes qui regardent
enfin autre côté il mais il y plus de
hashtag mais juste des hashtags parce
que tu caches ta une bitstream asta je
t'avertis un génial tim ream l'acheter
kevin hashtag plh tac boum et utah jazz
mais j'ai fait que les attaques m'a
collées partout tout ce qui passe par la
tête
allez nico nico au [ __ ] ni coton
qu'ont ces quatre noms il fou qui
protège et merde j'ai pas vu je voyais
pas le fou en fait caché chez énervé
mais je peux éviter le texte devait
exister après parfois est merdique oui
complètement
j'en peux plus jpp jpp bondé qui a
laissé sa d'un faux pas le choix c'est
mieux qu'une qualité kf4 dans la qualité
après
mais avant de centrer
mais je crois ce qui se passe avec
nicolas batum que ça normalement pour la
colonne concept dur tu penses à cause de
la donner c'est de faire 2,5 la torah
sur feuilles c'est autant monter le roi
en fait de 6,5 fedis
je comprends pas bien joué super passif
trop passif trop beau ce fait
on va voir un pro dîner on va tromper
laisse moi mais ça c'est pas mal joué
ici je pense cette date où tout est bien
apprécié je suis en train de tourner le
système de vide bessat tour ce bundle là
tout est bien là
nami l'adulation je pense minutes cette
manne bon c'est nous qui l'avons
d'accord donc retali marche sur le
tournage on saison en garde des sceaux
presse contre pire on like où cette
chasse comme qui lag mais là ya un souci
si vous ne vous de toujours une baisse
qui a gagné ses deux autres chasse qu'à
gagner darwich est ce qui est pas mal
hein peut-être on peut regarder des
roach est contredit ce patch
assainissent candidats avant plus non
mais n'importe quoi non je vous renvoie
votre pourquoi mais en fait ce qui est
ce comme qui ces pièces comme qui en
sueur ouais vous notre connexion elle va
pas ce que regardent le stream a primé
vert c'est génial connu qu'on a eus h
carte des super-lourds sa puce faire
coexister besoin urgent temps je regarde
de l'autre côté
mais je comprends pas mais en fait c'est
horrible les coups s'enchaînent pas quoi
du coup
cette partie je crois que en bonne
position non mais ça arrive de partout
qu'on ne peut pas vraiment voire wonders
ocz est en train de gagner une dame ou
pas bon il ya une pièce sur quoi comment
ouais ouais mais c'est chaud puisque on
va être là on l'avait tellement que ça a
été horrible si oui si on joue ça va
être pire en fait 10 passes
j'entends des coups j'ai pas je pense la
position et qu'elle prend des kakis et
prend des quatre à trois je pense qu'il
ya le cul qui est prend ces deux dames
français doivent penser 9.5 maquiller
dans la calculer sa vie perso de chasse
calcul nous attendons à des clac clac
clac clac clac jeu s'est décousu ce
joueur ne s'est pas cantonné pas encore
oui oui c'est vrai il s'agit d'aller
parfaire son jeu parce que les richesses
passe autant de temps annoncé un jour
qui passe donne le temps et calcule bien
je lui conseille quand même parce qu'on
vit tellement partie longue
prends ton temps pire tu t'en vas y toi
tu perds aux attaques non rentable par
vierge aux échecs le temps danse m'a
passé ne peut toujours leur destin
alors après un jour manuellement quoi tu
dois piquer bref voilà ça vient pas et
qu'ils admirent sa mairie va perdre
d'argent
il ya peu de temps et c'est compliqué
mais j'aime pas évidente à jouer
je tenterai cavalli c6 un truc de fou in
absolument avec l'idée sur bouffe tout
cas ici je pense pas mal joué même
problème j'ai pas vu non mais j'ai pu me
sur coup un eurobond gens bien belle
idée mais en fait c'est hyper dur être
commentée enfin gers et n'importe quoi
alors nathalie coup on se dope le ton
doit arrêter le stream quoi faire
peut-être temps le fameux tir frêche on
va voir on peut très bien ça remarche
vous demande d'ici superbus leader t-bag
et la coupe blonde alarmant
non c'est un événement qui est trop
regarder vos pas spoiler on peut pas
spoiler ouais on avait dit il a aussi
brillé aujourd'hui ouais on avait dit
que la russie avait gagné ses 2 0
c'était 2-0 mi-temps n'apprendra pas
précisé si c'était mi temps pas toi
droit 2-0 à un moment mais on a annoncé
la victoire de la russie au évidemment
non mais ça se fissure
on le savait un nano source napperons
peut dire que l'équipe de france ne
gagnera pas le mouvement soit poubelle
ça on le sait aussi
pas de filtre il dispaccio s'impose au
départ il va être dispatchés barreau de
chaise cela donne des primes ou veut on
partait de trop loin qu'en matière à
regarder des arceaux diving terme tous
que c'est la norme
fukui ses quatre fautes de main à ce
qu'un beau tennis tu fais une faute de
pied coin fort rebond bon évidemment ça
arrive à une pression de plus ou moins
normal narines et pas que sur iis et
c'est peut-être le prénommé le simple
speed machin kouassi est appuyée sur une
pièce qu'avec une case où elle partait
dire ouais je rappelle j'adorais ce que
les docteurs fait sur le cas de ces cinq
cas les vitraux un coup c'est bien ne
jamais jouer des quatre semaines qui
peut cliquer sur ces pour voir les
prendre il peut que jouer ses cartes de
tulle l'inscrire ne jamais gracier
désarmer le truc taille est parti comme
ça mais je vais bien secours rapidement
tu serais pas écrit celle de la rue r
c'est bien c'est au contraire
zai total et que le mec il me tend un
chèque d aimer sa pièce à découvrir ou
quoi c'était une bonne option quoi je
sais pas s'il est battu
non mais ça va pas être un spot une
suggestion pour écrire c'est vrai que
c'est assez fun et des fois du pouf alim
coincé grosse affaire mieux pas mettre
un échec avec un seul peuvent pas une
nouvelle roadmap ok mais ça marche pas
du tout dans un genre tu pourras
cercueil dont great falls 2 mais bon il
tente le beau jeu qu'on peut pas
reprocher non non pas refaire pour
conseiller à tour en séries tu vas le
faire tous ces 5 et coulissant vers oui
pas mal de me 3 aussi il faut enfin
c'était bien aussi mais nous faire du
dôme g3 j'imagine techniques dessin pas
d'accord
c'est pour coulisser ce qui n est qu à
tour carrée ce bon vieux pour le blanc
d'ailleurs avoir deuxième d'options on
va rencontrer un abonné de genève dans
samedi d'avant je dis oui on n'est pas
très longtemps à genève quand elle
n'avait que quinze minutes peut-être si
on a le bon train mais voir quinze
minutes c'est déjà beaucoup
htc qui vous a offert les micros ah ok
super du coup il est super heureux et je
lui dis malheureusement à cause de la
grève parce qu en fait j'aurais voulu
prendre le train de 13 heures de barrage
vous rentrez machin qui n'existe plus
parce que en fait mais moi j'ai envie de
rester une heure et demie à genève qui à
boire la variété de ces machins discuter
et puis je peux avoir le l'actu c'était
sympa et mais du coup il me dit que sur
le site suisse a le train à 13 ans lui
lier les français peut désigner payet
agraire et les suisses se dit qu'il y
est tu peux acheter le billet en fait si
tu crois qu'il a invoqués dans le doute
abstiens toi quoi donc je crois plus les
suisses les français pardon pas je crois
plus les suisses en fait parce qu'au
quai fait un bond de balma des français
ne font peur mais les français me font
peur mais
mais oui parce que sinon on aurait
presque du trésor ok ça faisait presque
même de parcourir oppose deux bagages le
rencontrer afin hockey en plus nous
allons vers les buzz et coordonnateur de
la chaîne et tous à des supers places de
train d'en parler un peu comme ça avec
lui et puis même voir le fasse pas mais
j'aime bien je n'ai fais toi tu n es pas
je devais de plusieurs fois je veux
quelques tournois là bas c'est une ville
agréable qu après donc c'est un peu cher
mais qu'il voit comme j'ai vécu pendant
quelques mois n'ont pas sauvé d'attajdid
quoi avec plaisir mission paraît là
c'était une heure et demie mais bon plus
comme la gare et août au centre tu peu
facile à la cornavin de corner à présent
mais l'atelier sur les deux joues bien
l'os la présence il faut du souffle mais
ça aurait fait plaise mais éduquant fait
jamais bon et même penser que tu as
passé une nuit en fait la matière mais
foin de ces cas la grève le lendemain et
témoigne des tons changent d'expression
mais mais mais du coup on fait toile 22
23 24 et à leur happy days
pas de chance non ne trouve pas les prix
fantastiques je sais pas j'ai pas vu les
prix pendant très longtemps c'était
fantastique wayne le rappeur il ya des
prix de ouf parce qu'on publie sur les
deux jours j'avais joué déjà et c'est
assez fort
résultat les déboires qui jouait
alexander firent tout mccow modena par
neto je sais plus masos effet avec moi
une fois dégrisé 32 bits et j'ai fait 3e
du rapide
deuxième du cumul et christian gine
famille et bon enfant c'est un fils
d'être chargée de liquider le cumul est
sain et bon tout les cadres et
avez-vous le fondeur sanofi jeu bref et
mauvais c'était vraiment des groupes et
là je crois que sais-je a peut-être 400
francs suisses ou 500 ou 300 alors
suisse il ya des six dévalué par rapport
à l'euro
chahut sur des manuels ce qui a été
remontée à 1 10 dans un mois je crois
qu'il faut que j'aille la boxe thaï van
noten comme je préside m
et pendant deux trois nuits le quai
quand je suis pas sûr du tout eu le
temps d'aller par l attaque tinto
reprend 1,5 dame proche des cartes ya
plus de temps mais sur vos pions premier
buteur proche des caprices prise est
arrivée la table se protéger et padam
solide ça marchait pas mais ouais donc
est ce que je sais est coupée mais oui
tout moi je les dois je faire un bon
plan prendre un nom mais ok mais c'est
juste que j'étais pas au courant de la
baisse absolument c'était peut-être
mille francs suisses qu'est mille francs
ça valait le coup mais surtout je pas
très loin de 5 à 8 ans la voiture aux
plantes à la masa ok je vais vous
répondre ça qu'on me prend à fermer en
fait fermer ses rivaux tels en france
mais c'est beaucoup plus beau faire non
plus cinq ans wii no ma bosse sur les
pubs pour la beauté des trucs là je dors
mal je reporte je vous quitte à être
mari tué si on était resté une journée à
genève je serais bien allé afin prendre
l'hôtel as tu as qu à ferney moi
j'arrivais toutefois orange fait plaisir
jacquillat et vient aussi qui touche
juste d'ailleurs c'est un peu gros non
même si à un moment je vais arriver à
l'étonnante je sais plus ça touche quoi
d'autres se sont jamais jamais voir des
gens qu'il n'a pas vus et abel qui fait
qu'ils aient bien quoi mais du coup on
regarde beaucoup et des réseaux mais
j'ai pas d'argent qu'ils ont pas réussi
à s'inscrire à l'aréna a posteriori quoi
et j'ai bien c'était quand même le monde
qui regarde payante pour les tournois
blizzard
écoute c'est pas très grave mais ouais
donc du coup je trie on peut on peut
prendre un petit truc à macha à ferney
on reste en soi mais non puisque tu
malade c'est peut-être pas la meilleure
idée pas beaucoup de natation va
probablement pas faire parce qu'on
ramasse surtout la grève en fait de
toute façon pas ce que fait mon chemin
ils ont quoi sombrer mon destin comme
sasuke quoi donc
donc c'est un peu problématique mais bon
quand bien même c'est dommage qu'on
réussisse pas à savoir si ce sera 13
heures parce que enfin ça change rien
pour nous et ça nous aurait pas permis
de te passer une après-midi d'un bye bye
n'a pas non plus en dessous de 11 heures
à 13 heures bah du coup on voit des
infos parce que les trains circulent
entre genève et lyon samedi
on est preneur ouais 13h20 ce que le
train yves à quoi je fais je paie ses
voeux de l'unc raymond oui pourquoi pas
on pourra peut-être mettre de la crème
henry oui oui surtout que oui surtout
que je n'ai voyais comme utiliser la
gare elle est vraiment centre-ville
c'est pas une ville où tout simplement
plus le même jeu la france 11 heures on
pourra arriver prendre le train allait
en vines resort à un débat on regarde un
peu le flou qui ont déçu tatata monsieur
fillon repart sans le train et on est
bien
oui carrément
mais bon après le train j'ai l'appui oui
sncf donc impression pour choper moi je
peux prendre le billet direct avec la
prie donc si on arrive juste à leur fric
la chine de ricine héberge cette chaîne
si quand elle est utilisée bas alors
elle héberge pas vraiment il ya un
hébergement automatique
peut-être qu'elle héberge pas par là que
je veux que je rechange que j'ai des
preuves que l'hébergement automatique
jeu fera partir de jeudi prochain pour
aujourd'hui les mecs on était un peu
même date jeudi prochain aussi suffit
pas je serai mais là du coup c'est un
peu spécial parce qu'on à budapest et fo
ont fait plein de choses
ces fêtes de la musique jeudi prochain
de musique
mais du coup je suis étonné de ce truc
de genève mais de façon c'est pas si
vous êtes dans le coin de genève comme
ça vaut le coup d'oeil le tournoi du
coup un oeil dessus en attendant toi ce
week-end prochain fsg ajoute la
fédération
je n'ose et de la sopab riesser de
tuning ce panel cette life vieux je fais
appel à un soutien s ouais mais bon je
crois que c'est gilles grall s ils s'en
occupent
ouais donc depuis longtemps là-bas son
petit boulot
en général chaque fois que choisit
j'étais contente je te dis j'ai
l'impression que les frais que ça va
m'engager par rapport au wynn à mesa
l'on m'a trop effectivement il aurait
fallu qu'il a un poil plus proche vous
voir go voiture à l'erreur alors ben mon
nom soit chez soi la d2 allemande
mais non c'est trop c'est à une heure et
demie tu aurais pu non c'est dommage que
ça se reflète sympa mais après tout on
doit pas être super fois revu les prix
qui s'annonce va s'associer à personne
il faut savoir quoi mais rarement
personne personne c'est pas possible il
n'existe presque pas la région la plus
forte
mais après tu vas voir un peu les locaux
non mais l'autre cause c'est pas si
grave
a toujours des mecs qui peuvent venir
souvent il ya des quatre chefs et leurs
troupes qui venait elle s est ce parti
20e grégoire opération échec est une
relation sportive des chèques de l'oise
en effet si la chanson force et je ne
vois c est cher
est-ce que ça a été fait je dois dire
c'est un sport sain je pense que c'est
genevois ont déjà choisi viendra
l'excellent batteur wars 2 7e tour tous
joué trois puces ou cachés mais ouais ça
c'est un bon tournoi mais ensuite j'ai
je sais qu'ils ont aussi j'ai des élèves
qui joue ça tu sais les petites coupes
c'était des découpes cantonales ce truc
sympa par équipes
france 3
oui on prend dam des trois matches ouais
ok franche pas d'accroché semonce qui
joue bien à la fin il faut vite mais il
joue pas vite et avant peut-être outre
le juste milieu
veut-on bord 2000 autrefois je pense
qu'un bon mais ça subir la souris quoi
jeudi trois chèques qu'il faut faire je
crois que les gens sont en train de
dominer le pré move ouais bah victoire
dans l'esprit alors médication plus
rater un est marrant cette semaine
le gagnant de ça pour les blancs mais
l'affairé reste que sur g4 darroch
l'autre tarot h 4 en revanche la tuerie
sever ok on va gagner
rush 5 g iii enregistré un creux f2
fallait faire rager quatre précédents et
encore ne jamais mélanger quatre énormes
en fait sur route de ne surtout pas
jouer au hockey surachat préfère g5
non non non farewell nom peut pas par
moi je prends juste une autre personne
pour agir geoffrey n'ont rien qui ait 20
f de kate fairway f2 roi gk3 j'ai deux
noms sautent aux yeux faire rager trois
mois je sens que le retour mais
vachement 3 5g 4,3 g saint moi j'ai trop
jeu sinon c'est vrai choix si je gagne
mais tu as dû te trompe at non mais tu
as fait et après beckham les roches à
tous partis n'ont pas le choix ranger 3
alors ça va gagner ça
c'est joli comme ma position
depuis ce drame non mais ça c'est beau
comme si mal il faut faire le pas tu es
tu pousse à fond j'essaie 3g 6 faut que
je te faire à 5 du bouclier b 4e ronde
ou soit la taille oui monsieur vraiment
du tour du g6 micro sachant ce qu'il y
ait un poids de près vous bouffez pouce
aux frais move tout là haut up mais non
ce qu'on disait comment on fait pour
voir les coudes qui fait à six il prend
je fais à cette île avancent tu fais à
huit dames nous tous et ouais bah du
coup est ce que c'était vraiment gagnant
je me pose la question qu'on se
questionne par là ok ça c'est normal
non ça c'est déjà trop tard non bon ça
l'a dit à sa mère parce que travaillant
h4 et l'autre en danger la même chaîne
mais du coup alors c'est juste ça pour
[Musique]
ça
dans ma vie mais j'ai compris de pardon
non mais surtout pas rejeter en fait fin
surtout pas ok faut tenter robe de tulle
appâtant g4tv 3,5
tu feras g10 agissante il attend
maintenant je viens là c'était salon
d'aidan pétrole mais il attend pas mme
way différents achats elle transpose en
un parti mais la jauge avait un temps
d'avancé par rapport à l'autre est-ce
que ça suffit bah oui parce que brave 5
3 5e plus on gagne de temps en fait les
saunas et ça on va défendre ou de gaz et
bloquer man down feat
non mais je pense le pr news canton
récurrent de pajr est versée par les
deux cases mines et j'ai 2 et 4 et tu
continues comme ça tu l'as pas tous les
noirs s'ils viennent là tu reprends
l'opposition il doit partir et on monte
on fait ça et si vous la partie c'était
sympa l affaire pour le stage salaire
intéressant de nico
tiens et ain taya qui en arrivent et y
en a un peu regardés ce qui fait
qu'entre dispatch hockey qui varient
vendée si ça c'est pas non mais non mais
là tu te fous pour encaisser 7
bon ok c'est pas faux phonique et des
quatre fers 6 août ouvert je veux qu'une
tombe 4 quand même vous chacune pour moi
vraiment quoi tu n'as pas le choix là
bas tu te fais changé plus pas
normalement faut prendre au moins deux
pions sans trop l'être et assuré
qu'alain cavalier invite un jour
éventuellement pour montrer et tata des
dames les quatre échecs face et c'est
très douteux collines et du coup ça se
passe si clair encore tout de suite s'il
vous est tristounet ce soir au pas
vraiment c'est plus le moment un petit
peu on parlait de tout et de rien mais
avant on était tellement chaude en outre
les nigauds contre kenny qui aurait fait
de folies et tout c'est juste qu'on a un
peu grillé
je n'ai plus de voix quoi ou un peu
grillé notre énergie du coup on discute
un peu plus comme ça des chèques quoi
sommes très technique comparaîtront à
genève des machins trucs
maintenant quand tu n'es pas triste fin
quand les passages je ne suis pas assez
sérieux
après chacun pourquoi mais il choisit
parce qu'on a beaucoup de style est
différent en fait deux parties le stream
de stream ça tu fais un truc pédagogique
je fais relève la pièce c'est de la
merde pour cela il ya beaucoup de
variété je les invite les femmes qu'est
ce que ça que ça corresponde retrouver
cette non mais ce plafond pour regarder
son cavalier même peut-être c'est pas si
mal je sais pas mais c'est mon jour a
pas fait autant ce serait très bien joué
monsieur fatigués qu'ils ne comprenaient
rien qu'en amérique et le mec n'est que
de remettre complètement nue là se
classe deuxième chose que je disais que
parfois si tu pas convaincu que tu
prends toute façon qui me jouer beaucoup
souffert d'un bébé de feu de moteur au
sort
ces quatre focale marmande cette
parcelle
allez-vous c4 focalise on savait pas de
tout reprendre les deux cela tourne en
l'air non mais t'es un cas elle est
inquiète pas un tweet which to which f1
c'est léger discussions une fois qu'on
est avec fable vous ça me fait penser
mais je comprends mexes pas méchant
badge rassemblé 5 vraiment ici pour
attaquer le terrain dit avec la dame la
chance c'est même ratant et steve a
battu garde à vue sur les coloris au
jarret pas faire non mais vous êtes à
sauver ne serait pas fait parce que je
leur ai prouvé que c'est trop risqué par
rapport à la boîte âge que j'ai quoi toi
pareil même français de faire saisir
dawn fiction âgé d'à peine 16 avril
vouloir vous je sais qu'il est bien
établie par malsain c'est tout à son
blason en outre l'ugtg pas comment ça
non à un moment c'est vrai on est un peu
juste en dessous donc à nouveau ouais
mais en fait part à ces discussions mais
à c'est intéressant c'est sympa de
penser mais si wayne nos journées sur
l'ongle avec le style en ce moment et du
coup m à la fin au début on était
complètement à fond pour nikos aaf on a
fait du nico afin d'entourer fuite voit
d'autres atours ses vingt cinq c4 c5 bon
pour tout gagner les élections il en
reste moins de points gagnants de suite
huras est pas on sent que sa technique
en finale c'est pas maintenant mais ça
va aller
oui mais jamais on sent que c'est un
secteur où il faut travailler
à
retrouvez nico en bas après on saura
bien descendre cinq minutes y'a semaine
dans la 9 minute deux minutes petit
musée deux parties bailleresse nico quoi
nico qui fait 12 pour un niveau qui fait
pas un gros travail obligatoire si tout
mais on voit que tu as raison plutôt
chaud et en français 5 devient le match
de la russie doit finalement pas si mal
je pense qu'ils ont pas très bien joué
mais peut-être les est très tendue aussi
au début du match c'est beaucoup à
perdre et finalement en deuxième
mi-temps il manquait les autres on va
avoir mal joué mais aucun match d'une
surtout c'est pas leur confort ouais
franchi par an si l'on répond avoir tu
vois marqab note bien villard ok super
bien ça sera bon sur le toit de l'été
faut le savoir faire ça donc time he
came to tenu tête chambéry chef shon
j'adore la pollution j'ai bien envie
d'envoyer d'autres préparent un coup de
tours ont besoin d'autre part on va le
savoir en fait j'ai pas là quand je fais
je vais coller un échec
le ca direct et à segré mais bon
peut-être que tu as deux couteaux
préparatoire l'île de man et les chocs
en fait j'aurais tout le monde s'est tu
auras chute
assad à ce qu'elles facturent f4 ouais
pas mal traffic jam un crochet par attac
et h5 d'un barrage trois registres
tachiev sata près du coup ils récupèrent
non mais cette fois même donc on dit
quoi toi f4 peut-être et wav 4ème bien
ouej 4,4 ok je jouerai québécois fou
voilà peut-être faut faire qu'à
l'épreuve des gens se débarrassent de ce
truc qu'on libère notre toit impliqué
cette manoeuvre c'est ce que je disais
on se libère du même oeil
tu peux lire même phrase la tour et par
type pailleron j'ai dit moi je vais
aimer le style même s'était amassée nico
était noir c'est ça le ferait gt qui ont
emballé par le style no made in time to
me l'envoie dans chaque partie ce n'est
pas toujours correctes mais ça je vous
dise pas comme ça les gens qui envoient
ce soir j'en vois quoi en ce sens que
ses fans de léser les vrais fans de la
chaîne quoi il joue dans le style à fond
quand ils envoient de ouf
en fait c'est bien envoyé bahdja tu
démarres plus tueur de bronze ta
pratique tend vers un peu j'avais un peu
les tchats britain shenzhen a envoyé
grave mais des arceaux qui joue solide
qui a eu ses échanges et les dames et
qui est maman pose des questions je vais
l'apprendre j'ai 3 kw et cavalières 6 à
mon avis b6 parra joue aussi un aspect
psychologique
oui ben oui donc ça va la chaîne verte
et bien oui mais bon tout changé
peut-être bon c'est un pion g4 donc pas
peut-être un peu de ces deux-là total
d'unités quoi c'est du respect pour le
changer car on respecte - points
commencent par le pari poliment que vous
ferez pas s'y intéresser
longtemps foods 3
mais on fait 5 est vraiment quelqu'un
qui a toujours fait trinquer pro v6
aussi jouable on a visité avec lui
florian mais ça je pense
quelques alliances et 90,6 aux essais 4
s'était formé dans un bosquet rossi
après la fille de 23 ans tu t'en fous
voilà la partie peut pas être une
manière passionnelle parfait tu es
injuste tu es toi y'a pas de nouveau je
te propose de donc ces perdants web à ce
que j'ai fait à la fois avec une dame de
moi le mec a compris que fera jaser au
combat et du coup il a accepté qu'à une
dame del pech maynaud et 6 passes il
annonce qu'il va subir un bug ça devrait
pouvoir se finir c'est un parti marié eu
un débat avec rennes tu mangeais dit non
on va finir sont pas un mais c'est un
peu débile pour gagner le chantage enfin
moi j'aime bien tous les week soit
recrutement aurait on fait quoi non mais
c'est vraiment un sujet complètement
débile
fall et la partie moi j'ai une importe
quoi que je suis athée comme un conte
genre 4,5 pouces et quatre matches à
savoir si c'est pas de chance je vois
toi mais du coup ça me fait marrer de
faire sans faute une cagoule et autres
apple rim dont il a dit j'ai besoin de
prévoir jusqu'où ça donne une dernière
partie un des brothers dispaccio refusé
non messieurs c'est marrant parce qu'en
fait tu as l'air partie cycle et en
importe quoi fins t'as intérêt à musquin
est complètement débile au début et pas
chez basse à mettre en place et en sueur
kerimov et surtout pas n'importe où at
on vu sais pas c'était pas clair
3 je veux d'ailleurs d'aller c'était mon
parti a gagné d'herseaux chess à des
richesses il a rasé crypte acceptable
est parti je crois pas qu elle se finit
2e qu'on a mal il a fait six sur sept et
s'était mis sur 13 et bravo à kalma des
raisons qui vont à nouveau ce père fut
beau tournoi
tu m'etonnes tout pas mal qui fait ça
tenir ici mais qui est moins de strict
par contre ni qu un peu déçu quoi un
nico en demi teinte on va débriefer tout
ça bon bah les mecs grand merci d'avoir
suivi
c'était assez marrant on s'est bien
marré ou en tout cas et je vous dis à
lundi pour l'aréna sur la chaîne blitz
rim est ok a tout le temps les deux
femmes déjà presse ils vont sortir de
partout ciao ciao